Hello everybody, it's Dr. Kevin Connors. It is the 29th. Hope my date is right. Maybe it's the 30th.
What is the date today? Let's see. I better look real quick. I'd have the wrong date on there.
Oh my goodness, it's the 30th. I better change this. It is the 30th of May from the 6th. How time flies.
And it is 2018. I hope still. And we're going to talk about some questions that people had sent in
and to clarify a few things and announce it or two. And then jump to questions.
All right, so first things first, I realized that going through any difficult disease process,
you're not feeling well, it could be depressing sometimes. And we all go through depression.
At least most people do. I do sometimes and I just get bouts of sadness and melancholy. And that's part
of grieving process. It's part of life. It's part of the emotions that God gave you. I don't think
it's bad to have those emotions. I think you'd be a denial if you don't have those emotions.
And it might be unhealthy. I'm going to start a series and I will be posted. It will actually have a
web page that you can go to for this series. That's going to be called Dr. Sees. It's my 7-day
soul cleanse. It's not going to be 7 days, but it's really 7 parts to it that you can take over
seven weeks or whatever you want to do. And it's basically going to be some preaching.
So if you believe differently, if you're faith wise than I do, maybe a little challenging to you,
but challenge you to at least listen to it. You'll be up on the website with the next week or so.
And I hope that will help you because I do sometimes I do things as you'll notice. Sometimes I
teach things because it's what God is teaching me. So I feel like part of this ministry of a clinic
is for as my responsibility to share with you what God is sharing with me. And you could disagree
with it. You could agree with it. You could throw it out. You could ask God to reveal the truth that
He needs you to know through it. And that's what everything that we talk about. I don't claim to know
everything. And I do believe wholeheartedly that the more I do learn and know, the more I am revealed,
how little I absolutely know. So this series that's going to be coming up is really to deal
less with health things even though they're all interconnected and you can't separate.
With the two, but it's to deal with that spiritual emotional side of healing. So I look forward to
be able to share all that with you. Now under the topics of the day, we want to clarify some things.
And multiple questions come in. And these things I really feel like they need to be clarified.
So one of the things is clarified ozone. I spoke about ozone last week. And one of the patients
said it felt like I was kind of downplaying the benefits of ozone in cancer therapy. And I wanted
to clarify that a little bit. So multiple ways to get ozone into the system. And that is the key.
So can ozone be beneficial to kill cancer? Yes. The struggle with it is, is that ozone by its very
nature is very unstable. So even if we inject it into our blood, the chance of it getting to my cancer
site is minimal or the chance of getting to my cancer site is not very high. So that's my struggle
with ozone. Now if you have the other way to get ozone is infiltration through putting it into
a bag and then doing it rectally. So rectal ozone is a very good way to get it into your system.
It goes through the bloodstream there. But still as it gets into the bloodstream and travels through
the blood to get to my cancer, the chance of it being stable until it getting into the
capillary bed and then into the tissue and getting to my cancer is very slim. Now the difference is,
if I have rectal or colon cancer, ozone is perfect, right? So different types of cancer,
ozone is going to be a great choice. So one of the patients who want to be to clarify this has
rectal cancer or colon cancer and they were using rectal ozone. And I had told them it's great,
that's a great therapy, but then they heard me kind of dis-ozone last week and like they were confused.
So it depends on the type of cancer. So if you're getting, if I have
breast cancer and I'm going to do rectal ozone or ozone through the bloodstream is what's the chance
of it getting to my breast cancer? Probably, it's pretty slim. But if I have colon cancer and I do
a rectal ozone source, that's a great tool. So it gets back to there's different therapies that are
have greater benefits for different types of cancer. So you've heard me say, okay, what besides the
rife would be good for my cancer? Well, it depends on the cancer. If I have liver cancer,
my first choice for a secondary therapy would be the PEMF or the hyperthermia. If I have breast
cancer, my first choice for secondary therapy would be the hyperthermia and then maybe the PEMF.
If I have prostate cancer, hyperthermia would it be on that list? It'd be the PEMF.
So it depends on the type of cancer that you're dealing with. Is that therapy a real viable therapy?
If you have endless pockets, you could try everything and do everything. And that might be a good
choice. However, everything takes a lot of time, too. So maybe that's not the best use of our time as
well. So always good. If you hear me say something on this and it's not protected into your cancer,
you want some clarification, just email, make sure you put in that email header, something that's
relates to zoom so that we catch it. Remember, please don't email a bunch of questions through email,
your email will most likely get buried. If you have questions call the office or put on the email
header on the subject line, zoom question. So it could see, I literally get 100 to 200 emails a day.
So it will chance to be seen, it can be slim. So I don't want you to think that we're ignoring you.
Also, Facebook is the form that you need to use to get your questions answered. If it's more of a
more personal nature than make sure you call and schedule a time to talk to myself or Angie or Michelle.
And we'll get those questions answered. The other clarification is about Facebook feeds.
Somebody called today or yesterday or something, it said, I'm really concerned because I posted a
question on the Connors Clinic patient's only page and it came up in my news feed. Okay, so
understand the way Facebook works. Any groups that you belong to and the Connors Clinic patient's
only page is a group. If you post something to that group or somebody else post something to that
group, it will come up in your news feed. Now, because it comes up in your news feed, does not mean
it comes up to the public. So don't confuse that and I understand it can be extremely confusing.
Oh my goodness, this is just a regular news feed that I'm looking at and my post came up in there.
Oh my goodness, can everybody see that question that I asked? It's kind of embarrassing. I don't
want the world to see that. No, they cannot see that. Only people in that group can see that.
So but your posts in a group will come up in your feed. It does not mean that it goes to the
general public nor can any of other your friends see it. Nobody else in the world can see it except
those that are in a Connors Clinic group. So I know it's misleading because oh my goodness, it came
in that feed but nobody else can see it. So make sure that you're clear about that. So feel secure
about that. Also, another little clarification about Facebook. For the most part, we are only
allowing patients on our Facebook group page. We do sometimes if there is some if the patient has
an advocate that is doing most of their communication with the clinic for the patient, many times if
the patient is very ill, their husband is doing most of the communication or vice versa, they are
allowed on the group. But for the most part, even spouses were trying to not allow on the group
unless they are the patient advocate and certainly friends on patients. And I know many of you have
have suggested your friends to get on the Connors Clinic patient's only group page and I have
denied the request. So I don't think I need need but this is a privilege for patients only not
for your friends and such. So just so you know, this is supposed to be a private group just for you
guys. So that's why we're trying to keep it. Other clarification about RIF use and foot baths. We get
questions on a weekly basis about the use of the RIF and using other programs. Okay, so make this
perfectly clear. The RIF should be your first go to for everything. Now I do not believe the RIF
is a panacea for every disease known to man. But it should be your first go to. I have an earache,
run the ear infection program. I have, you know, use your use wisdom if you broke your arm. Don't try
to run a program on the right to heal your heart. But it should be a go to program. I have a rash.
I should run the inflammation program or find a program that may be fitting. There's poison ivy,
I think, programs on the right. So try to use the right as a tool to help with any of your
ills or any of your problems without becoming a crazy hypochondriac that's that's your husband
divorces you because you're sitting in front of the rife all the time. But it should be your first go
to tool. You can't hurt yourself. Run in any programs on the rife. So use them.
Clarification about the foot baths. Make sure if you're using the foot bath apparatus, you are
switching. Follow the instructions in your manual. Flip the switch to bath and
run only ion pro wave programs with your foot bath. Do not run other programs with your foot bath.
There are programs to be run with the ball. That's 99% of the programs on your rife. And then there's
a folder that says ion pro wave. Those are the programs that you can run with your foot bath. Now many of
you I have put an ion pro wave program that I want you to run in your folder. Many of you I have
it. But the ones that have that in your folder then run that program. So just be clear about that.
Look up your instructions. Every one of you is given a rife manual spiral bound kind of thing.
And just look that up if you're if you're unclear about that. If you have to call the clinic,
you can go ahead and do so. The rife function. We had a question come in that I missed. Sorry,
you know, who you are about the function of the rife. What does it do? You know, is it if it's
killing bacteria things? Is it a killing by old cells? Boy, we could have a couple hour discussion
on the different theories on how rife frequency works. There's multiple theories on how it works.
I do cover this in some of my videos that are on our website on rife theory. But just real clearly,
is it damaging my old cells if I'm running a program? I do not believe there's any damage to your
normal cells. If I'm running the liver frequency cell program and it's running through normal
liver frequencies, it's helping bring residents to my liver cells and it's going to help my liver
cells function better. Rife believed that running a frequency of a cancer and his whole thing was
trying to tune into that frequency of the cancer. If you could hit that cancer with its own frequency,
he would cause lysis of that cell. And that's with how he believed he had success with cancer
patients is that there was cell lysis. Now, I do believe that that may occur, but I don't believe
that that usually occurs. If you do hit a cancer frequency with its own, cancer cell with its own
frequency, remember a cancer cell is your human body cells. So if you have breast cancer, it is a
breast cell that is in a rapid replication phase. What are the beliefs of rife? And I do believe that
this does take place many times, is that when you hit a breast cancer cell with its own frequency,
a breast frequency, a breast cell frequency, you bring back normal residents to the cell and the
cell stops rapidly replicating. That's why you don't always get shrinkage of the tumor.
So remember, what a cancer is. Cancer is cells that are in a rapid replication phase. Well,
therefore, over time, there's a lot more cells. That's what a tumor is. So a tumor is cells that
are replicating. Therefore, they're getting more of them and they're getting larger. And then with
cancer, they're not going through normal apoptosis. So you're getting a mass that's getting bigger and
bigger and bigger. And I've told you a hundred times that our goal is not to make the mass go away.
That would be wonderful. We just wanted to stop growing because if it stops getting bigger,
then we know it's not replicating. So if we can stop its replication, this rapid replication,
it stops, quote unquote, being cancer. So it fell off the definition of cancer since the definition
of cancer is rapidly replicating cells. So if we can get it to stop replicating, then we win. So that's
the goal of this all together. So one of the theories of life is that if you hit a cancer cell with
its own frequency, liver cancer or breast cancer, and you can bring residents back to that cell and
it starts acting like a normal breast cell or liver cell again, it stops replicating. That doesn't
mean the mass is going to disappear. So you have to get it out of your head that this mass in my
breast may never go away. And that's okay. We just got to get it to stop growing. So that's part
of the function of the life with cancer. No, there's at least two dozen other theories that all are
viable and they probably are all applicable with how frequency medicine works with cancer. So now
nothing is going to work beyond God's desire for it to work in your life. So we are dealing with that
as well. So we have to deal with what the sovereignty of God has planned for the days of my life with
this, but we're supposed to be doing our part. So the rife is not a magic tool. It's not going to be
a cure-all for everything all the time, but it's going to be a great tool for us.
And then lastly, before we open it up to questions, I want to clarify some things about the IVG test.
You know, remember what the IVG test is measuring. It's measuring free cell DNA. It is that free cell
DNA. It's measuring tumor markers on the circulating tumor cells. So out of that, it's measuring
are these tumor markers? The tumor suppressor cells are those percentage of those tumor suppressor
cells that are turned out or turned off. And the tumor, um, good genes, whether they're turned out
or turned off. I mean the tumor suppressor genes, not tumor suppressor cells. So understand from,
when you look at the DNA of a cell, you have all these different DNA that you can look at. Now there are
tumor suppressor genes, and there are tumor oncogenes. So an oncogen, if it is, quote unquote,
turned on, then it can stimulate a cancer production. It can stimulate growth. It can stimulate
replication. Now, tumor suppressor genes, if they're not turned on, then it will lack suppressing
the oncogenes, kind of confusing, but tumor suppressor genes suppress replication, tumor suppressor
genes decrease replication. That's why if I have defects in numerous tumor suppressor gene pathways,
my risk for cancer can go up. And my ability to suppress cancer goes down. So that there's two
different things. When we look at your genetics, we're looking at your tumor suppressor genes,
and we're looking at do I have defects on those tumor suppressor genes? And I could have, let's
pretend, I have perfect genes, and I have no defects on my tumor suppressor genes. Does that mean
I will never get cancer? No, because getting cancer has nothing to do with tumor suppressor genes
per se. It has to do with toxins. It has to do with things that got into my cell. It has to do with
my immune system response. And yes, does it have something to do with tumor suppressor genes? Sure,
if my tumor suppressor genes don't have any defects on them, and they are turned on, then I will
more readily suppress any cancer that's growing. If I do have defects on my tumor suppressor
genes, and then the ones that are functioning are turned on, I will readily suppress the tumor
that's growing, but less than if I didn't have any defects on that gene. So there's multiple
other factors. We cannot just look at my tumor suppressor genes. We have to look at, are they
methylated or not methylated? That's what the IVG tests. So the IVG tests is not looking at do I
have defects? It's are the ones that I have turned on or turned off, and are the ugly genes turned
on or turned off, and that percentage is putting it put into the factor that gives us our IVG score.
So like any other blood test out there, any other CT scan, any other MRI, it's not going to be perfect.
But it does give us a measurement that we could read out where our cancers at.
Okay, now I'm going to open it up for questions and unmute everybody, and I do ask that we try
to keep to one question per person unless nobody else has any other questions.
Dr. I know this has kind of been explained to me before, but I still have a hard time with
understanding the difference between like the IV gene, Anka, tumor markers, and the regular like
when they just do a blood test on me, and they give me my tumor markers. Okay, so I'll mute everybody
at answer that. Okay, so let me slow down so I don't miss quote of myself and use wrong terminology.
So there's tumor markers that a person can test, and if you have a cancer that shows tumor
markers like CA19 or CA125, those are tumor markers that can be prevalent in certain types of cancer.
That's a blood test, and it can be extremely accurate for some people, and it can be inaccurate for
other people, and for other people, it might not even show up. So let's use the CA125, for example.
Typically, that's fairly accurate with people with colon or colorectal cancer.
However, I've had patients with colorectal cancer that their CA125 doesn't even show up.
So it's like, okay, well, if it doesn't, you're not even showing high with CA125, and yet you have
colorectal cancer, and you already had a section of your colon removed, and they're doing chemotherapy.
I mean, there's no doubt that you don't have colon cancer, and yet you're not showing the CA125.
Well, we can't use that as a marker then. However, in other people, the marker is a very stable marker,
and if you look at it as a trend, then you can see that trend up or trend down, and you could use that
as a marker. So a cancer marker is a blood test that you could use, that you could use as a guide,
as you look at its trend, to whether your cancer is improving or not improving. But you need to look
at the trend of it. The IV gene is looking at the genetics of the circulating tumor cells, the
free cell DNA. So it's just a completely different marker. So it's a different thing you're looking
in your blood. It's just like when you do a blood test, and they look at albumin, or globulin,
or red blood cells, or white blood cells. These are different things they're looking for in the blood
depended upon the test, and they are markers to other things. If I have a low red blood cell count
in a low hemoglobin, then I have some sort of an adenemia going on. So it's a marker to some other
disease process. So it is with tumor markers there, they can be a marker to a cancer, but they don't
show up with everybody. So there isn't a perfect marker out there, and there's a lot of
a lot of cancers that don't show positive tumor markers. That's the struggle. The other struggle with
tumor markers is if the person is doing chemo, it tends to strongly skew the tumor marker score.
That's why a lot of oncologists don't even test for tumor markers anymore.
So it's if you go into a oncologist that they have tested for tumor markers, and yours
were high when your cancer burden was higher, and it's lowered when you've gotten better,
then that can be a good marker for you. Okay, I'll unmute everybody, and hopefully that answered
your question. If you still feel confused, let me know. I guess what was explained to me as the
tumor markers in the blood work is just like measuring the protein, and they said protein is like
a secondary indication of either it could be cancer growing, or it could be cancer being killed
off too. So that's what's so confusing to me. Well, that's why when tumor markers were first discovered,
it was really super exciting, and this was going to be a lot of invasive way to see how my cancer
was going, but as we realized that it became very difficult because typically when a person does
chemotherapy, your tumor markers can spike, and I could scare the daylights out of the patient like,
oh my gosh, I thought it was doing chemo, and this is supposed to be getting better. I go through this
misery of chemo, and my tumor markers went up 10 times. Well, it's because the cancer was going
through a lysis, so it was eliciting a lot of that protein, and then it read in the score. So that's why
a lot of colleges don't like to run tumor markers, especially if that's a person's dream. So it's not
nothing's going to be perfect ever. Dr. Connors, is there anything to do to lessen
a sitease accumulating so fast? So a sitease is when the cell membrane is becoming
quote-a-quote leaky, and then fluid is draining from the cell from intracellular fluid to outside
of the cell. So when we measure your biometrics, when we measure that when you were in the office,
ever one of the measurements that we looked at was intracellular fluid versus extracellular fluid.
And what is intracellular fluid versus extracellular fluid? A measurement of. It's really a measurement of
the integrity of the cell membrane. When our cell membranes have less integrity, though,
that usually comes with a cancer patient with their cancer cells rapidly replicating the health of
that cell membrane as well. And you start to get leakage of fluid. Secondly, you get a sitease
from fluid, from capillary leakage as well. So water is leaking and many times the reason why it is is
that minerals are being lost. And what minerals are collected in the extracellular spaces,
it's changing the dynamics of waste flow and water flow. So minerals attract water to them,
and therefore you get a buildup of fluid. So how do the only real way to decrease
the sitease is to do things that will strengthen your healthy cell membranes, the cell membranes
of your healthy cells. And then you go, okay, what are my cell membranes made of? Your cell membranes are
made of a phospholipid bilayer. So good fats, coconut oil, olive oil, and phospholipids.
So if you want to go directly to the source, that's where you use a product like
phosphatidylcholine. And that's why we've been using more of that. That's that PC, the phosphatidylcholine
liquid, or the phospholide product that's a zymogen product, they're actually both made by the same
company. And as I imagine, just private labels it. So that using a phospholide, a phosphatidylcholine
product, good fats are your made key. Now I will clarify something else about a sitease. So
the typical light of thought with the sitease from an ecological perspective is that a sitease is
going to be occurring in later stage cancers. And you'll get some oncologists that will tell you
that, oh, well, you're starting to get a sitease. This is what happens in end stage. So they won't
give you a lot of hope like you need to prepare to die. You got a sitease going on. Well, the truth
is I used to think that two several years ago, because here you're starting to get bloating,
we need to go in and have that that fluid drain off. Oh my goodness, this is good. But we've had
patients that have had fluid drain off for a couple of years now, and they get it drained off. You
know, they might have two, three leaders plus dried off the first few times they do it. And then
pretty soon, as it starts to heal, they get less dried off, less dried off, they get less
the sitease. And you can recover just fine. So don't believe their thought process and don't allow
it to be put in your head that, oh my gosh, it's over. I'm getting all this fluid billed up. And this
is the end times here. Don't believe that. This is just another process through your healing process.
The best thing that you can do is to go in and get it scope to see where the sitease is. If it's
the abdominal cavity and get it drained off, you will feel a ton better. So that pressure from the
sitease, all that fluid billed up is making you miserable. It can really make you feel
lousy. It can really drain you. It can cause you to feel full. You don't eat as much if it's an
abdominal cavity. If it's in the lung cavity, you can't breathe as well. You're having a hard time
getting air in. Don't let that fluid build up. If you're going in multiple times to get that
drained, meaning more than once a week, they will suggest that you put that they put a permanent
temporary drain tube in. I'd suggest you give that some serious thought because then you could
drain it yourself. And you will notice, so a lot of our patients notice that, wow, they're getting
less fluid and less fluid and less fluid and they're feeling so much better again. So don't think it's
the worst thing or worst case scenario. Just get it drained. If you could get it drained, the
only thing that you could do from not just a natural perspective, but any perspective is support the
cell membrane health. I'd also suggest, you know, there is to make sure you're getting some mineral
content in if you're not taking minerals because if you're losing minerals into the abdominal
cavities cavity or the lung cavity, it will draw water with it. So if you keep a steady mineral
content in your bloodstream, it will help hold the fluid from your from your from your losing from your
bloodstream. What are the minerals? Okay, sorry, I just unmuted you. I have to unmute you everybody
after the questions because we get feedback from people's phones. We are taking the
phospholine except the last week or so he can't swallow those pills. Can I do anything? We're coming
to the clinic next week, but in the meantime, can we do anything to get that down? Can I melt them
in something? He could bite them. Okay. He could bite them. You could stick a needle in them. It's
quarter of his mouth. You could stick a needle in and then have it bite it and it was already as a
hole it'll squeeze out. It's an oil, it will taste good, probably, but so on. So you don't need
the outside of the pill? No. And how do I get minerals? Just as a mineral source. You're already
he's already taking minerals, is it he? Is it he taking a mineral capsule for us? I don't I don't
know. I don't think so. Okay, just if you want to remember to ask that question on Facebook
that I could follow up on Facebook. Thank you. Another thing, Dr, that you gave me advice and I was
having severe ascites for a while there. My cancer was advancing and you could tell me about getting
in my hands and doing regularly all the things because part of my problem was was cancer in my left
note. Yep. And it wasn't draining and that really did help. I was getting a lot of fluid in my legs
that I was doing the exercises where I'm doing with the muscle like you were saying to flex the muscle
lot and that was that was helping. Okay. Okay. So what she's talking about, I'm going to mute everybody
again. So what she's talking about is I gave this exactly advice to somebody just this morning.
So if I have ascites fluid filled up in my abdominal cavity, I can then end up getting fluid
built up in my legs and my legs don't drain very well and I get swallowed ankles and such.
Why is that? Okay. Well, the way the fluid drains is through your live system that drains into your
veins. Though your veins don't have a lot of pressure for the blood coming back and your veins are
very, they'll squash down and just like a hose, that's maybe one of those flexible hoses that
will once you take the water out of them, they've flopped to nothing. That's kind of what a
vein is like. So if you have fluid, a bunch of fluid in your abdominal cavity, it can push on that
vein and literally squash it. So then the flow back for my legs isn't going to be that great.
I actually my blood pressure and my ankles is going to rise and my capillary bed is going to get
even more leaky and I will increase swelling in my legs and that can be extremely uncomfortable.
So the same thing that I teach pregnant women to do, so this is a problem, a pregnant woman has too
because she's got a baby growing in her stomach that is literally squashing her inferior vena cava
going back to the heart that's draining her legs. So I tell them to, oh, one way is to lie on your
back and get your feet up. Well, that helps it really does because you're using gravity to help pull
the fluid out of your legs. However, lying on your back is putting all that baby pressure or all that
ascites pressure directly on the inferior vena cava and it's branches. So another way to do it
is get on all fours and just relax your tummy and allow your tummy to sag down. And then what's
happening? The ascites or the baby is flowing to the front of your belly towards the floor and your
inferior vena cava, which runs right along the spine, is opened up. That hose is opened up. It'll
help your legs drain. Also, your lymph flow functions on muscle contraction. Your lymph system has no
capillary heart pressure that is going to make it flow in a direction. The way your lymph system is
open ended capillaries that have the valves one way valves in them about every two to four inches.
So it's only only upon muscle contraction that the flow goes in a certain direction. So from your
legs, you're standing up, you're sitting, you need to contract your muscles in order to get that
lymph flow back upwards and cross that valve and be held back and continue to push up that
that vascular system through valve, through valve, through valve back up into the where it drains into
the vena system again. So those are some hints to deal with the swelling and the extremities and such
but you do need to deal with the asideies in the abdominal cavity and the lugs don't be afraid of
getting that drink. Dr. Connors, the hammer bulb on the rife machine, the all-night program. It's my
understanding that it is DNA repair because you explained to me how that works.
So no, the hammer bulb that's in you that you're doing your all-night program, it is not
just DNA repair. Matter of fact, I don't have DNA repair in most people's. I have that program
based upon your cancer. So that's based upon known frequencies for your cancer, frequencies
based upon what we found as what we believe the cause of your cancer is and your hits on your
skin. So it's not just DNA repair. So I would, you know, and I don't remember if I have DNA repair at
yours at all. So if you do feel inclined to run that DNA repair program during the day, for sure,
do so if you have time. Okay, all right. What is the one, oh, then it's programmed specifically for
me and my type of cancer for the night? Yes, it is. And the new hammer bulb is more effective.
The new hammer bulb? I thought they have a new... They do have a crystallized hammer bulb,
is that the one you're talking about? Right. That's the one that I have now. Yeah, you could use that.
I don't, you know, do I think that crystallized hammer bulb is more effective? I don't know. I have
what I've been experimenting with and I'm not completely convinced that it's more effective or not.
But if you have one, use it. I didn't. I certainly didn't know it's different. Yeah. But I'm using it. Yeah,
I didn't either. That's why we don't push it. They're more expensive than I just haven't,
you know, I try things and I'm not convinced that it's a lot better yet. So.
Thank you. Thank you. You bet. Okay. Well, I think we will wrap it up for the day.
We'll get this up on a Facebook page as possible. Make sure that you email questions in again
and you do put in the subject line that it's a Zoom question so that we make sure we get your question
answered. And we'll get them on the next Zoom call. We'll be looking for our 7-day
Soul Clubs coming up very soon. Thanks much everybody. Thank you. Thank you, Dr. Conner.